Matt Whitaker is the former acting
Attorney General of the United States He
joins us tonight to assess Mr Waker
thank you so much for coming on so
um explain if you would why the Trump
case and the Biden case are really not
as different as they're telling us on
MSNBC well they're on the one hand they
aren't different because we're dealing
with classified documents and we're
dealing with the statute that applies to
them and their handling but on the other
hand we're dealing with a former
president who had a lot of latitude
while President to declassify those
documents that were in his possession
and Joe Biden as vice president had no
power to declassify those documents that
were in his possession I think it's also
interesting fact in this case Tucker
that the UPenn documents had were in a
manila folder marked personal and so you
open it up and all these marked
classified documents are in a personal
folder you know this this is not good
for Joe Biden however I think ultimately
you know this is going to get down to
where Jim Comey was at with Hillary
Clinton and it's going to come down to a
applying the standard of the statute to
the facts as we have them there's
nothing in the statute about locked
garages certainly and there's really
nothing about whether or not uh you know
you disclosed it as soon as you found it
I mean Joe Biden had these for to your
point over six years right
so I mean whether or not you think this
is an organized effort from within the
Democratic party to prevent Biden from
running again I think it's really clear
that it is I'm still confused as to why
we don't know the details why haven't
they told us why they were searching six
years later for these documents who was
doing it like what is this and why won't
they tell us
well there's a lot of facts we don't
know if you remember famously in the
Mar-A-Lago case they spread out the
documents on the carpet took a picture
sent that to the media made sure that
everyone saw the evidence in this case
we don't know much about the contents of
the documents we don't know much about
why we were told that it's because he
was moving out of uh the pen offices and
his lawyers were going through the
documents but then why go through the
garage you know why and really the other
thing that is very concerning about this
case America Ireland waited four weeks
to appoint a special counsel when he
knew on December 20th that he had a
major problem and they were hoping that
this never saw the light of day and
that's really a sad fact about this
whole case is they didn't want this to
the American people even know this had
happened yeah and that is I would say
the definition of corruption we have a
right to know yeah former acting
attorney general the United States Matt
Whittaker thank you so much thanks
Tucker great seeing you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight